okay I make that time thank you very
much for coming along it's great to see
quite so many people in for a session in
an afternoon
that's a deep dive into the kind of high
performance code so obviously no one's
asleep yet and it's still got some
capacity to to take this stuff on
welcome my name's Steve I'm a Microsoft
MVP and Pluralsight author my day job is
as a senior developer for a company
called magics base down in Brighton
where we do software as a service
recruitment technology mainly I also run
a meetup group down there called net
southeast which is a monthly event so if
you're over in the Brighton area check
us out and hopefully you can come along
and join us today we're going to talk
about writing high performance c-sharp
code and I do want to highlight this
bitly link here so bitly /hi perf net is
where you'll find all of the slides and
all of the code that I'm going to show
you so don't feel that you have to
photograph every slide as we go through
if you go there you've got it all so
make sure you've got a a picture of that
and you can you can follow along later
if you want to get in touch after the
talk I'm online at Steve J Gordon on
Twitter and my blog Steve J Gordon code
at UK has a lot of the content that I'm
going to cover today in a much more
detail so in some form or another you'll
be able to kind of dig into some of the
stuff if it doesn't make sense today
hopefully those blog posts will sort of
take you through the rest of it I'm
going to try and pack in a lot in 60
minutes so in the in the interest of
optimizing this piece of the talk we'll
skip past it so I want to start by
talking about the aspects of performance
because I think it's really important
before we start talking about how we
optimize the code we understand what
we're trying to achieve and so for me I
boil this down to free kind of main
areas and the first is kind of raw
execution time and this can be the
execution time of perhaps an entire
process within your application code but
quite often this could be sort of
measuring how long does a particular
method or even parts of the code within
a method take to actually execute
because as a general rule the faster we
can make our code execute the more we
can do with that particular device
pretty closely tied to that is frupa and
this is a measure that's actually more
easy to measure in production because
this is something you can track over
time
and it's quite well affected by
execution time and this is a measure of
sort of kind of how much work you can do
so in a web application this might be
requests per second for example in a
queue processing service a worker
service you might be measuring how much
you can actually process of that queue
in perhaps a minute or an hour and this
measure as I say you want to track in
production because you can kind of see
you know trends over time you could
alert on this data if some of those
numbers go down you're handling less
requests and you were expecting you
could per second that might be a sign
that something that's been recently
deployed has affected your code and
again tie quite closely to both of these
is memory allocations and if you've
watched people like then Adams on
Twitter or David Fowler from the
Microsoft team you'll see them quite
often talking about trying to sort of
allocate less in their code the reason
this is important is although allocating
is a very fast and quick operation
creating a new object is not really
problematic we do pay for that at some
point later in time so anything we
allocate on the heap is going to need to
be garbage collected at some point in
time and that introduces potentially
short pauses in our application while
that takes effect and this can have an
impact in high performance situations on
on how your code is overall going to
perform if you're giving CPU time over
to the garbage collector that's time you
could be spending in your own code so
these are sort of the key areas that
we're going to look at and see how we
can potentially optimize some of these
areas in the code today it's important
to remember that performance is
contextual a lot of what I'm going to
show you today is not relevant to your
day-to-day pieces of work you're not
going to want to go and apply these
techniques in everything you do but
there's gonna be maybe ten percent at
the time where you are are writing
something we're in he's the scale or
handle huge volumes we're looking at
more performant code could save you time
money on how you're going to scale that
service so bear in mind that this is all
contextual and you need to think about
in your given situation is it
appropriate to go to some of the depths
of what I'm going to show you today it's
also important to remember that with
performance there tends to be a bit of a
trade-off with readability of your code
and so you've got to kind of thing is it
more important that the code is easy to
maintain and if it's regularly changing
you've got lots of developers working on
it you probably want your code to be
reasonably readable so that you can
maintain it and make
but if the code is a micro service and
it's designed to do one thing and you're
writing it once and hopefully not
modifying it too often then that's the
time where you might be able to say well
actually if we introduce some of this
high performance code that we accept is
going to make it harder to read we're
not expecting to change that too often
and actually the benefit of you know
scaling that service less or being able
to do more with one instance is actually
worth the time and effort to do it so
just be aware that you know there are
some trade-offs to these things so when
we start looking at how we're going to
improve our code we're gonna go through
what I've sort of deemed the
optimization cycle it's a pretty sick
print simple cycle we start by measuring
it's really important in performance
optimization not to make any kind of
assumptions about what you're doing even
things that you've done in the past that
have improved code somewhere may not
actually have the same effect somewhere
else so measuring your code is is is
vital really to validating that what
you're doing is having a positive impact
the first step is measuring before you
do anything find out what the current
state of the application is but maybe
starting with a higher level profiling
type approach to understand what are the
hot paths in your application and then
once you know where the code is being
executed often and what's being called
the most then you can start to focus in
on doing sort of code level benchmarking
and actually looking at optimizing those
pieces of code and improving them once
you've got those measurements and you
know you're starting place then you want
to begin with some optimization and in
this phase it's important not to get
carried away and do tons of changes at
once it's quite tempting when you're
doing this to go out can apply span here
and this there and and all of those
changes at once means that you don't
really know if all of the changes you're
making have had a positive impact
overall you might have improved
execution time or reduce memory
allocations but is that the best you
could have achieved the best way to tell
this is to change one small thing and
then measure again and at that point you
can validate your previous assumption
make sure that you've had a positive
impact and then try the next thing and
really that's just a simple cycle that
you're going to keep going through and
depending on what your objectives are
for that application you may go through
this once or twice or you might keep
going at this until you've really think
you've hammered every ounce of
performance out of the code that you're
trying to improve so there's various
tools available for measuring
application performance I'm not going to
go into these in too much depth but I do
want to kind of touch
just that you're aware that these are
sort of a starting place for a lot of
your codes in terms of profiling Visual
Studio has some quite good tooling built
in these days so I think David Fowler
was showing this the other day you know
there's diagnostic tools built into
Visual Studio that you can even run
while you're just debugging your code
and even there you could do things like
see what your memory traffic looks like
taking actual CPU or memory snapshots
and analyze them as your codes running
now be aware that you're in debug mode
your codes not in the most optimized
compiled version it's designed for
debugging so it's it's it's gonna be
slightly off from the performance you'd
see in a release application but it's a
good indicator you can start to have a
feel for what bits of your code do
allocate and what sort of volumes and
memory you're talking about once you've
sort of done it in debugging you're
going to want to do some profiling
hopefully under very realistic loads and
this might be in some kind of replica
environment where you can hit something
we have a number of requests that mimic
what you've seen in your real production
system or in some situations you might
be safe enough to take some form of
profiling in your production app and you
might use Visual Studio tools to do that
perfu was shown again by David Fowler
quite a low-level tour quite hard tool
to actually get your head around but
very powerful lots of options there
jetbrains do trace and dock memory which
are kind of a nice middle ground they
offer a little bit more power in some
areas but they have a better UI
make it a little easier to work with and
occasionally and this isn't something
you're gonna have to do all of the time
you might want to even look at the the
IR code the intermediate language that
your C sharp or F sharp code is
compiling into when you build your
application things that you can sort of
see in there you can sometimes get a
hint of where you're doing some boxing
operations or your you've got lots of
virtual method calls going on or just
the raw number of instructions can give
you an indicator that perhaps you can
you can optimize that code somehow they
say it's not something you're going to
all of the time but it's there as
another sort of tool in your chest that
you can kind of go for it's also
important to remember that you do want
to be monitoring this stuff in
production and having real metrics
around it particularly if you are going
to be trying to change a lot around
performance sometimes in your test
environments you might see positive
gains you want to make sure you're
realizing them in production and you're
monitoring over time so
you can alert and changes in those
environments so these are sort of
important tools to figure out where they
fit into your your development processes
but that's all I will spend more time on
today because it's more sort of akin to
direct code improvements and actual sort
of code performance optimizations is
benchmark dotnet so this is a library
that you can bring in it's an open
source library it's it's very well
maintained and what it's about is doing
high precision monitoring of your code
and this is giving you really good
accurate benchmark results about memory
allocations execution time of code
typically you could get really basic
results by putting a stopwatch around
some code but you would have to run that
actually quite a lot of times to get a
very realistic count particularly on
pieces of code that are only executing
over nanoseconds because getting an
accurate measurement of that is very
difficult so benchmark net does this
very scientifically it will do many tens
of thousands of iterations of its
benchmarking so that it can cast out the
outliers give you a statistical average
on the data that is collecting and it
will also measure its own overhead so
it's ensuring that the actual
measurement process itself isn't
affecting the results you're seeing so
this is a very scientific way of going
to collect the data and this is the tool
that Microsoft now use within core FX
which is the dotnet core sort of
framework and inside asp net core for
making sure that they understand how
that code base is performing as well so
it's a very powerful tool and you can
also include it in your C ICD process if
you want to so you use it while you're
improving your code but you could also
have these things execute on builds so
that you can see if you're actually
introducing regressions around any areas
your code that you've kind of identified
as critical paths that you don't want to
break so we're gonna have a look this is
like a hello world of benchmarking so
we'll start with this so basically what
you'll do is you'll create a console
application and you'll bring in the
benchmark dotnet libraries so a bit like
creating unit test projects and then
we're just going to have a very simple
program main method here which is going
to call down to the benchmark runners so
there's various ways you can have
benchmarks execute the simplest way here
is just to say to run and then give it
the class that contains your benchmarks
that you care about and so below I've
got my benchmark
class here so at the moment I've got
this attribute at the top which is a
memory diagnosis so this is where
benchmarks is gives us control over the
type of information that's collected and
reported on here what I'm saying is I
also want as well as execution time I
want some details about memory
allocations when you run benchmarks
within this class then I have some setup
code this code is is outside of our
benchmarking I'm not measuring the heap
allocations or the cost of establishing
these objects this is objects that I'm
gonna operate on what I'm interested in
is testing what it is what it takes to
run that get last name method of my
posit ID so inside this method here
which is marked with the benchmark
attribute to identify as a benchmark
that you want to run we have some code
and this could be code that points to
another project reference that you've
got but it could be just arbitrary lines
of code in there that you want to test
in isolation as well so we've got our
benchmark we're going to run it now so
what we're gonna do is we're gonna make
sure that we're on a release build
benchmark that will not let you run the
tests on debug code so it will give you
a warning it's quite obvious if you've
done it wrong and you're just going to
run the code inside that console
application so it's gonna run for a
while it's going to spits out a lot of
information about all of the warm-up
phases it's going to do all of the
overhead measurements and then finally
all of the actual iterations of the
benchmarks it's running and finally when
you get your results you're going to
have a bit of a summary you'll find out
what sort of platform you were running
this on top of and then for each
benchmark within that class we would
have a row here we've got the one row so
we can see one hundred and sixty-three
nanoseconds to X occur execute that that
particular method we don't really know
at this stages is that good is that bad
it sounds pretty quick I guess but we
only at this point really established
our own baseline for this code execution
now because we included the memory
diagnosis or attribute we get this
additional memory information so here we
can see first some information about
potential garbage collections that will
occur so there's various different
generations that your objects can live
within this sort of managed memory and
this is essentially giving us a view as
to how long those objects lived within
the the code base while those benchmarks
were running so we can see everything is
in Gen Z row so all of the objects that
were created were short-lived so that's
a bit of an indicator that you know
there's only the allocations
of large or they aren't living for a
long period of time and we can see this
measurement is actually slightly hard to
calculate because it's per 1000
operations
so it's naught point naught 3 7 per 1000
operations which in this case is around
26,000 times we'd have to call that
method before we might have introduced
enough GC pressure that a GC would
actually have kicked in so we can see
it's reasonably efficient in terms of
we're not putting a lot of load on what
we're doing and we can validate the
actual allocation of bites here as 160
bytes now it's important to remember
these measurements may be scaled
differently that might be kilobytes or
megabytes depending on what you're
measuring if all of the results will be
at the same unit that you just don't
always assume it's bytes basically and
that is now a point where we'd be able
to go and start doing some optimization
of our code so I want to like now bring
in the features that are you're probably
all here to sort of hear about and see
and the first of which is span of T so
this was released in the last couple of
years and it's generated a fair bit of
buzz I think I'm always interested how
many people have heard of span of T
already most of the house good how many
people are using it in a production app
1 2 3 4 5 I can count them across the
room so yeah this is pretty indicative
and pretty sort of expected I see this
pretty much everywhere I ask the
question and I can understand why
because in a sense Microsoft have
publicised this quite heavily because it
is introducing the possibility for them
to really optimize core effects and asp
net core so they're very excited about
it because it's making the framework and
the platform quicker for us to work
against but they have always cautioned
in those posts this is cool don't use it
and they kind of do that because it can
get you into a sort of more gnarly world
of code and they don't want everyone
picking this up just because it looks
cool I sort of annoyed them a little bit
by saying I do think it can be used more
than they are promoting it I think there
are more use cases for things like span
of T that I've been prototyping where it
hasn't made the code to much more
complicated and I have got a reasonably
good benefit out of there and we'll look
at some real-world prototypes that I've
been doing in a moment for you to kind
of make your own judgments on that but
it was introduced in dotnet core 2.1 it
is available also for dotnet framework
as an additional library package you can
bring in that
refer to a slow span which is a bit of a
misleading term it's slightly slower
than the span that's in dotnet core
purely because in dotnet core they were
able to make runtime changes to support
the feature being as highly optimized as
possible so they're both fast they're
both perfectly usable and you can use
these in both places if you need to
what span gives you is a read/write view
over some contiguous block of memory
which is very wordy sort of sentence so
essentially if you think of something
like an array which is on the heap
that's a contiguous block of memory
that's allocated on the heap in one one
nice block and we can get a spam viewer
over that which doesn't sound hugely
useful because we could always look at
it as an array anyway but the
interesting thing about span of T is
that you can target and view memory
that's on the heap but also on the stack
and also unmanaged memory and you can
work with it through this consistent fan
of tapi you don't need to worry about
where the memory exists and it will do
the right thing for you in terms of
memory and type safety to make sure
you're not doing things that would be
dangerous or will allow you to leak
objects outside of the scope that
they're meant to be seen in so you can
work on things like arrays and strings
on the heap but as I say you've got that
stack option which can you can use and
we will see that in use in one of the
demos as well or unmanaged memory if
that's where you're working there's
almost no overhead to using this it has
the same kind of functionality as an
array you can iterate over the array or
over the data in the span I should say
you can modify it you can take a
particular index and adjust that if you
want to and as I say it's very simple to
kind of do those kind of operations in a
very similar way to spam with
practically at so as an array we've
practically no overhead to doing it the
most popular operation that you'll do
once you've got a span and this is where
you'll start to see the power of it is
the slice operation this is where we
have a view over some data and what
we're going to do is modify that view so
here we've started out with an array of
nine integers which is a really strange
number to use like should have been ten
but I have my array so I can call our
span on that and that will return me my
span representation now span is a very
low and light type it's it's a value
type and it's guaranteed to only ever
live on the stack so there's no
allocation or
cost in doing this and it's essentially
inside just a pointer in a length over
the memory that it's looking at there's
a little more complex than that but it's
very lightweight so there's there's very
little cost of doing that once we have
our span view over this array then we
could slice into it and all we do with
slice is we get a start position and
optionally a length that we want to use
and this then gives us back another span
so now we have two spans looking at the
same block of memory so the important
thing is here this starts to give us a
possibility of parsing through some
memory that we actually have a view of
already without copying it we're not
copying data so there's no overhead
there's no real cost of doing this and
you can see here that my second span my
span to its index 0 would essentially
bear where index 2 is in that first span
so both of those can now operate on that
data and modify and view it differently
I prefer I sort of give the analogy for
this of photography so I do a little bit
of photography I have a DSLR camera with
those sort of telephoto lens many people
who have taken pictures with their
camera phones if you're taking a nice
wide-angle picture of a landscape and
you see an object down the middle of
that landscape that you're interested in
and you have a couple of options you
could walk towards it which might be a
mile across the field and over a stile
and eventually you get close and great
you've taken your picture there's a fair
amount of effort involved in that or a
fairly consistent operation is just
zooming the camera lens or swipe zooming
into the view and then you have a
different view over the same scene that
you were looking at previously and this
is what slicing is essentially and
because of that it's a constant time
constant cost operation so because
there's no allocations involved because
there's no memory copying involved it
doesn't matter here if that array is
nine elements or nine million elements
the cost of slicing into it for any
length or slice is exactly the same each
time we do it
so now I've sort of shown you that and
probably bamboozled your brains with
span because it does take a little while
to kinda get a get your head around
let's look at a slightly trivialized
example before we get to more realistic
code in a short while so imagine we have
this requirement given to us by the
product owner we need a method that
takes an array it's going to return one
quarter of its elements starting from
the middle I'm sure everyone's had a
requirement like this dumped on them at
work so that's the requirement someone
in our business had been given at some
stage and and possibly this is how they
might have been
demented it they might just use the skip
and a take in a link expression to give
the data that was being asked for and
they think great we've delivered now
sometime later the product manager comes
back and goes we want to we want to
turbocharge this thing we want to make
it really quick we want to make a
fortune this is going to save us some
money and so now we need to optimize
that code so the first thing I'm going
to do is I'm going to set up some
benchmarks so there's some additional
code coming but this is our setup which
is a little more complex than the hello
world example it doesn't have to be but
there's some good reasons for doing this
so the first thing here is this params
attribute on the size property there
this allows us to configure benchmark
net so that it will run this benchmark
actually free times or every benchmark
in this class in fact three times each
time it runs it though it will have a
different size value in that property
and the reason we might want to do this
is it's very easy to get sort of drawn
into testing one particular sort of
best-case scenario that you expect and
we always expect this array to be maybe
a thousand elements but often there are
edge cases to the data that we get given
and sometimes it can be different the
results of your sort of improvements
might differ higher or smaller sizes
here so we're going to test three
possibilities because I've got that I
need some way to set this this benchmark
method up so what I've got is a just a
regular method that I marked with the
global setup attribute and this gets run
once before the benchmarks actually
initialize and it's not again doesn't
measure in doesn't affect the execution
time or the allocations we see what
really just doing is creating an array
of the appropriate size that we're going
to operate on so now we can actually
write our benchmarks so this is the code
that our original developer had written
all I've done here is added a benchmark
attribute in this case with the baseline
equals true which says this is the
starting point of code that I'm coming
from so I want to measure everything
else against this and we can run that
benchmark and we get three results this
time because of the three different
parameters that we put through so we can
see that 154 nanoseconds two to four
bytes allocated in the first run 100
original sizer
for the array and as we go up as we
might expect because we were working on
larger and larger arrays we're seeing
higher and higher allocations and a
longer time for this code to execute so
this is our starting point we're now
armed with enough information that we
can make a change and see if we can
improve
so at this stage we maybe think well
actually I've heard linked expressions
might have some overhead perhaps we'll
write this code more manually so we'll
create the new array that we're going to
copy some data into and we'll see if
that executes better so we've had a
theory we've made one essentially fairly
small change here that we're going to
now measure so in this results that we
can see well actually great for this
first result of a hundred items we're
down to a much quicker execution time
and looks like we've made nearly 50%
saving on the bytes allocated so at this
point if we were only testing at the
hundred element size we'd feel pretty
good about the results because we've
added the additional sizes and we can
see actually with a thousand elements
the gain in terms of sort of allocated
bytes is fairly insignificant now the
difference in each case is actually 96
bytes which is the cost of the link
expression being compiled and executed
but otherwise the allocation cost is
pretty much the same it's obviously
quicker to run so this is a benefit if
we're looking for raw execution time but
perhaps we care about memory as well so
we're finally going to introduce spam
and as you can see we're going to able
to use the slice operation to give us
the same set of data this is a slightly
unfair test potentially depending on
what the caller can accept so here the
other ones we're returning an array now
we're returning a span of int to them
so we're on the assumption that the
caller can work with a span and still
use that in an optimal way if we were
just casting it back to an array at some
point we probably would have less of a
game but let's just see what span gives
us on the assumption the caller can work
with that and continue on an optimized
code path so when we run our tests again
with the span we're now under a
nanosecond and we have no allocation so
that's pretty good we feel pretty good
about that and if we look at 1,000 omits
well we're still under a nanosecond and
we still allocated nothing and at 10,000
the same set of results it's a constant
time constant cost operation so
regardless of the fact that we're
getting a bigger and bigger initial
array that we're testing against on my
particular machine this slice operation
takes about a nanosecond on other
machines it will vary slightly but
that's pretty good set of results so
already you can see in just this trivial
example that span can be quite a
powerful way if you're parsing data and
you just want to get a different view on
it essentially that you can do that with
basically no cost
and we can do this with strings as well
so strings are essentially just a
character array under the hood and so we
can call as span on a string literal or
a reference to a string but what we get
back is slightly different this time we
get back a read-only span the reason for
that is obviously strings are immutable
and if we were given back a readwrite
viewer over the data that that string is
occupying we could do some really nasty
stuff to the people that trust that
strings are immutable so we can only
ever get back a read-only span and now
we just have that view that we can read
over and potentially pass through so in
this scenario perhaps I find the index
of the last space character and then I
would slice to get my surname in this
then this simple example so we can start
to do these kind of operations in this
there's there's not much of a game to
doing it but if you're parsing a large
blob of tab-separated files for example
which we are to have an example of you
will see that actually the benefits
start to add up quite significantly when
you just want portions of that data now
there are some important limitations to
span of T that it's really important you
understand so that you know where and
when you can't apply it so the first of
these is it's a stack only value type
and I sort of hinted at that earlier so
what does that mean well it's it's
defined as what's called a ref stroke
this is a new keyword that was
introduced in c-sharp 7.2 and what this
says is this is a value type that you
can never store on to the heap so today
value types may essentially end up on
the heap memory at some point in their
lifetime but because this fan could be
pointed at stack allocated memory that
would be really dangerous because then
we can have this spam existing longer
before its garbage collected on the heap
pointed at memory that is is no longer
what it was originally looking at and so
because of this because it's built in to
the span of T feature that we're offered
this memory safety this guarantee that
we can only ever use it in the right
context with the memory that we're
pointing at because of that it can't be
boxed that makes sense we're not going
to be able to put this onto the heap the
big sort of changes that that might
introduce is that you're quite often
tempted to add this as a field in a
class or something but because that's in
a part of a class and the heap we're
running into the same issue the biggest
and most significant thing I see people
run into is
we can't use this inside a sink methods
basically we can't have it as an
argument or inside as a local variable
inside a sink methods and a lot of our
code today is asynchronous so in a
moment I'll show you how you work around
that because that would feel like a
showstopper I think to many of you and
the final thing is for a very similar
reason it can't be captured inside
lambda expressions and and the reason
for those last two is it may be not be
immediately obvious because in code it
doesn't look like you're breaking the
rules but when you compile these you end
up with a state machine in the case of a
single you may end up with a class for
the lambda closures that exists and
these mean that we're breaking the
earlier rules by then elevating this
span thing into a field on one of those
classes that get generated so these are
all the limitations we're running
against fortunately Microsoft also
introduced memory of T and this is a
very similar type to span of T with
slightly lower performance gains so it
can live on the heap if it needs to and
this is the critical thing so it can't
now be pointed at a stack memory but it
does mean that we've got this guarantee
that we can use it in some of the places
that we can't use spam so it's defined
as a read-only struct not a restaurant
and that's the key thing that ref struct
keyword use is what guarantees that an
item will only ever live on the stack
it's slightly slower if you're slicing
it has a slice operation it's just
slightly slower than what the spam flows
operation will give you so depending on
what you're looking for it might be
perfectly fine to accept that sort of
difference but if you're going for the
ultimate performance you're always going
to want to get back to a span as soon as
you can fortunately that's really easy
it exposes a spam property you ask for
the spam and that represents that same
area of the memory that you're looking
at with the memory of T and you'll
combine these two together so here we're
trying to do something that is making
the compiler really sad we're trying to
pass a span into this method that is
asynchronous so the compiler will check
this and see this risk it will identify
that this is not a legal operation and
so at this point we're not going to have
compiling code we can change the code
then to accept instead in this case in
memory of bite now the compiler is happy
again
and the way we're going to work with
this is we could just slice as I say
that memory and it looks very similar to
what we
were seeing with the spam but we're
going for every ounce of performance so
we want to we want to use a span
operation to slice it so the way you
work around this is you typically then
make a non asynchronous method at the
point of where you're working with the
data because once you have the data in
memory there's no real asynchronous
methods that you're going to be calling
and then this method can take a span in
so what you're going to then do is try
and pass that span from the async method
well here we're also breaking the
compiler while we're trying to create a
local variable that is a span it won't
let us do that inside this async method
so the way we work around that is we
make sure we just pass it directly into
the method here and the compiler is
happy with this it can figure it out and
do the right thing under the hood for us
and this is typically what you'll see in
async code you'll just drop into the
memory of T where you need it and then
drop back to a span where you're
actually doing your final optimizations
with it so I've talked for quite a while
half an hour so we're now going to
actually look at some some code quickly
so the scenario here was that I was
looking at building a prototype to
optimize some code we had in production
that piece of code reads from M sqs
which is just amazon's queue service it
takes the message and we want to store
it into s3 which is essentially amazon's
object store there blobstore in order to
do that we need to give it a file name
of an object key and I want to use some
of the properties on that original JSON
structure to do that so today the code
is deserializing getting the properties
to build the key and then actually
storing it in there so if I drop to
visual studio which I'm desperately
hoping works this time good this is like
the original code and I'm going to show
you the original code then the new code
and then we'll look at the benchmarks I
promise I did it the right way I
benchmarked as I went but it's just
slightly nicer for a reveal if I show
you the numbers afterwards so here I
have a method and it takes in this event
context which in this case just has five
properties in our actual scenario it's
got many many tens of properties but
we're only caring about a few of them
and what this original code which had
been slightly optimized anyway was doing
was it was taking that event context and
it was calculating how many of the
elements are we actually gonna use to
build up the object key and it basically
it's if there's no date we're going to
use four elements if there's a date
we'll use the date in the key as well so
then we get this string array of those
elements we get
doing away with the appropriate size and
what we're gonna do is start filling the
parts of that array with each of the
properties that we care about and inside
this get part method what it's doing is
saying if it's empty or it's null we're
going to just put in an unknown part and
that unknown part is just a constant
string we're going to use when we
haven't actually got the data in the
property that we're expecting if we have
got data we're going to try and remove
the spaces inside that remove spaces
method down here it's as simple if the
space is in the method in the string do
a string replace on them fairly
reasonable and then the final check is
is it a valid valid as an object key so
there's some rules around having only
characters and numbers in the object key
so we've got a regex that's checking
that for us and so that's essentially
the code and we're just going to
populate the parts of that array
optionally we'll do a to string on the
date to format that if we have it and
finally what really happens at the end
is we just use a string join to take all
of those elements join them into one
final string we want it to be lowercase
for consistency so we're going to lower
it and then we have our string so it
looks reasonable so I'll show you the
new one I'll just going to drag down
just to give you an idea this is more of
a boat to be fair and that kind of goes
to that performance versus readability
point it's and as you can see at the top
here don't worry about too much I have
some ugly-looking code where I'm
defining these things in such a way that
I can guarantee that I'm going to reduce
a mem copy I'm just cool just forcing
all of the performance I can out of this
you'd have to understand exactly why for
the purposes of this demo so the key
thing that I want to talk about is kind
of how I'm gonna use spam for
optimization here so I'm going to
basically create a character array that
I can use as a temporary building area
for the file name that I want to
generate and I'm going to slowly
populate that with the elements as on as
I'm going through so what I'm doing is
on pre calculating the length and the
reason I'm doing that in this this line
here is that down here I'm going to do
something a little bit clever which is
if it's only under 256 characters which
in the happy path I usually expect I'm
actually going to use stack Halleck to
allocate the temporary character array
on the stack and then this typically
would mean that you would have to use
the unsafe keyword and drop into unsafe
code if you wanted to work on the stack
at all because it is quite dangerous you
want to make sure you're not over
allocating on the stack or you'll end up
with a stack overflow exception
then you end up on stackoverflow trying
to work out why but if you if you're
only working with small portions a
memory and hearing on sub guarantying
256 characters I'm fairly happy as okay
I'm saying use stack but I can also hear
say actually if that's too big just use
a regular heap-allocated character array
as well but I can represent them both as
a span of T so this is where that kind
of transformation to a single type that
deals with either memory location is
quite convenient then what I can do is I
can build parts in of the string in a
similar way to before and what I pass in
here is the the part that I want to
start including my spam which is that
output working area and by reference I
pass in the integer which tracks my
position so I can update my position as
I go and slice to the appropriate point
in the the character array as I'm
building it so I'm basically doing what
I did before but slightly more of a bow
so if it's it's a zero length for its
whitespace only then use the unknown
part and you can see here what we're
doing is basically you're saying copy it
into that spam starting at the slice
that begins at this output position at
this start of this it's zero but what
then we will do is update that position
so we know how many characters we've
written in and so the next time we do a
slice we'll start from there and we can
continue writing into it if we have got
data in there we'll do an is valid check
and we can simplify that without regex
here and just do is character or digit
and we basically finally end up here
hopefully where we're going to use this
memory extensions type here - too low
and variant which means copy this input
string into this span area and lower it
at the same time so we can let the
compiler do some optimizations hopefully
so that's what we're essentially doing
in remove spaces it's a fairly simple
case of seeing if there's a space in
there by using this index of on the span
and if there is then we can take that
actual index where that space is and
just replace the character so we can
modify by using the indexer as well so
that's the code it's all on github if
you want to kind of dive into it in more
detail but I'm going to jump back to
slides and sort of have a look at the
results here so these are the results of
my tests so in the original approach
just over a thousand nanoseconds and
then we got down to 440
90 seconds four and a half two and a
half times faster not a massive
improvement really and depending on what
our objectives are that wouldn't be
particularly great but we were going
really after allocations we had a theory
originally that might be a lot of
allocations and so we can see that the
original code allocated because it were
using those things like string join and
then string to lower because strings are
immutable that means we're just creating
new and new strings for each of those
intermediate phases of building that
final key we have a fair few allocations
over a thousand bytes here in the new
code we have 192 bytes and 192 bytes
here is actually the length of the final
string that we allocate at the end of
the methods so we've achieved building
that string we've no overhead at all and
so that's quite a significant
improvement for us slightly supported by
showing it a second ago but on its own
this doesn't look super impressive but
we scaled this up to what this service
is actually doing it's doing 18 million
messages a day through this service so
that's 17 gig of daily allocations we've
achieved just by modifying this one
particular method flow in the code and
that's around 2,700 gem 0 collections
from the garbage collector that we've
avoided having created and the need to
do so this at scale starts to have to
sort of have compound interest really in
terms of the investment that you're
making so I'm moving on a bit there's
quite a few more features I want to
touch on a rape all of the first of
those it's really hard to work out what
this does by the name it's a pool of
erase it this is useful in scenarios
where you you regularly need a
short-lived buffer and you'll see this a
lot if you're working with streams for
example you need that buffer space to do
some work and then you're kind of
getting rid of it when you've done
something with it what we can do with
the array pause I'm gonna say well
actually we'll go to this thing that's
going to have a set of a raise for us
and they're just going to live forever
essentially inside our application and
the pool is just going to give us an
existing one whenever we need it again
so that's quite powerful it's found in
the system buffers namespace and the way
you work with this is you it's a generic
type so you sort of have an array pool
of whatever you want and typically what
your call is it's shared methods for its
share property sorry to get an instance
that's kind of pre-configured with
common pooling sizes that we might
want to use the reason it's a good idea
to use this is they take care of sort of
figuring out how to actually implement
or a pool itself but also this is shared
with the runtime as well so if we have
an array pool of int and the runtimes
also using the same array pool of in
we've already got probably arrays in
that pool that we can be sharing and
reusing so to get the item we just call
rent and we give it a length so we say
okay I want a thousand bytes so let's
say and it's gonna give us back an array
the important and really critical point
with this is you may get an array and
you probably will get an array that's
actually bigger than what you've asked
for which sounds kind of weird but it's
logical if you think about how the
appall is going to actually be
functional it needs to keep certain
bucket sizes of arrays available so that
it can give you a realistic reuse of
those arrays if you have every possible
array size Under the Sun in the pool
you're realistically ever going to use
that array once and they're all we've
done is just give a lot more long life a
lot of objects and we've not really got
any gain so you when you're working with
the arrays from the pool you kind of
need to track how much data you've
written into it so that when you later
iterating that array for example you
only go to the length that you care
about when you're done with it you
return it that's important otherwise
you've just created an object and cast
it away would eventually get G seed but
really all you've added is the overhead
of an array pool with no actual benefit
so you're in a worse place if you don't
return it we can pass this clearer work
array equals force or true through to
this method this is another important
point so before dotnet core free oh so
2.2 or earlier when you returned an
array to the pool it was not cleared by
default this isn't a performance
optimization that just saves a short
amount of time clearing that memory but
it confused a few people and it
introduced a potential security risk if
you were putting arrays back in the data
that you didn't really want to be pulled
back out again later so now it clears by
default but you can turn that behavior
off you always need to remember that any
array you're given from the pool may
already contain data which is why again
you don't want to just iterate the
entire array because you might be
talking and getting data at the end of
it that you didn't write into there in
the first place
so it does somewhat Kompany complicate
some parts of working with the array but
as we look in the example it's not
hugely complicated to do so here I've
got a short live buffer that I want to
pass into another method
and here we have an allocation on the
heap so what I'm going to do is change
that to the using the shared array pool
I'm going to rent one thousand byte
array the chances are here I'll get 102
four bytes or maybe 204 eight bytes but
you know it depends what's available in
the buffer it could go even bigger but
I've got my buffer and then I can work
with it now as I say we need to make
sure that we put this back so typically
they recommend using the try finally
pattern here to make sure that whatever
happens we do return the array to the
pool after we're done with that and
that's kind of a red pool we'll see that
in action in a moment but I also want to
introduce system i/o pipelines this is
kind of the brainchild of David Fowler
and the asp.net team originally so it
was originally created to improve the
performance of kestrel kestrel does a
lot of i/o it's reading network requests
off of a socket and then pushing them
through the kestrel web server into MVC
or Razer pages and into the side that is
B net and this is quite a heavy
operation because there were various
handoffs between different streams
through those different layers of the
applications so they were looking for a
way to optimize that code and they've
found that they can actually improve
working with streams by about 2x now you
could technically write that code
yourself that's all they've done but
they've wrapped it inside this type
because it's actually really really hard
to do so it's really just removing the
boilerplate of trying to optimize
streams yourself through this type the
important thing about the way that
pipelines work is unlike a traditional
sort of stream based approach you're
working with the buffers yourself and
you're managing those the pipe it's is
going to do that all for you so it's
going to hand you some memory that
you're going to work with and you're
going to just read out of it and you
don't need to worry about the buffers
it's also going to use the array pool
internally to do that so it avoids heap
allocations for those buffers as well
two ends to a pipe it seems quite
logical we have a writer and a reader so
what does this look like well we have a
pipe so we're first going to start
working with the pipe writers and when
we get the pipe writer what we can do is
we can say get memory this gives us a
memory of T memory a byte in this
example why memory well we're inside an
async method typically when we're
working through this we're going to be
doing some i/o within the same method so
there's likelihood of async calls in
there so we get a memory of byte we
would do some work with that data that
we've been given to put
some data into it maybe how I built up
the character array before for my object
key for example and when we're done we
just advanced by the amount of bytes
we've written and then when we're ready
we can flush it as well
flushing it is the operation that
signals to the reading end you've got
some data that you might want to look at
now so on the reading M we have a pipe
reader we can await the read async
method so it's a non-blocking operation
by default which is really quite
powerful it's not going to do anything
until there's something in that pipe
that we haven't already seen we get back
a read result on the re result is a
buffer and that buffer is interestingly
of type read only sequence Y read only
sequence and not memory well the reason
is the pipe in advance doesn't generally
know how much data you're going to give
it if you're streaming data off of a
network socket you might get a small
amount of data or you may get lots and
lots of data so the pipe has to be able
to create buffers for you as it gets
more and more data as those buffers are
filling up what it's going to do
essentially is create some memory of T's
off of the array pool internally and
then when it returns it to you it gives
you the structure of a read-only
sequence that just represents
essentially a linked list of those
buffers so that you can then work
through them as if it was one logical
piece of memory so this is how you're
going to be sort of operating on the
data that you get back from the pipe on
the other end so this again is easier to
see in practice so what I'm going to do
in this example the scenario here is tap
separated file parsing which is super
exciting
we had the scenario where we parse a tab
separate file that was stored on AWS we
we first decompress it which is kind of
important for this example but then what
we're doing is parsing that data and
getting basically just three parts of it
three particular properties out of that
each row and storing them into
elasticsearch so let's look at the code
for this and again I'll do the sort of
before and after code and then we'll
look at the actual improvement so this
is the before code again I'll just sort
of quickly go over it so essentially we
read in this case from a file just
because I didn't want to be using s free
in my example but we get back a stream
from history as well we would decompress
it and eventually what the original off
of this code was doing was decompressing
the entire stream to an array to in
order to create a long string that
represents all of the data in that file
and the reason they were doing this is
they're using this lie
we call tiny CSV piles of which at least
at the time I was sold only accepted
working with strings these files were
about ten thousand rows each so if you
start to think how much memory that
might be if we create a byte array that
represents the file and then we could
create a string for it this was setting
off some warning flags and we did
actually have some memory leak issues
with this service that led me to look at
it initially so what I've done instead
is they you are sorry what they were
using was this tiny CSV parser which has
this quite nice sort of fluent syntax
for kind of saying I want to read this
out of it and map it to these properties
so the reason they were using the
library was readability and convenience
but I had some concerns so the new code
again I will just show you for
comparison this is longer again but
hopefully something we can follow so we
start with the decompression stream as
before so we're going to use the pipe
here with a stream we use have to use a
stream in the early stages because there
isn't really a pipe that can decompress
at this point in time but that may well
come with the framework but once we have
a stream we can just create a pipe
reader over that stream and start
working with the other end of the pipe
basically so the framework will handle
writing into it we do the read async as
we saw in the example we get the buffer
and eventually what we're going to do is
call into piles lines passing in the
buffer what this is doing is its new so
we've got a sequence reader which is the
type that allows us to work with
sequence in a very convenient way
because that read only sequence type is
a bit of a pain to actually pass your
way through but the sequence reader
makes it quite straightforward because
as a method like try read to any where I
can say look for in this case the the
bytes that represent a newline character
if I've got a complete line I know I can
pass the it to actual elements out of it
if I don't have a line we're break here
and we'll wait till more data comes from
the pipe when we do have at least one
complete line we'll try and parse it and
in slow piles line we're kind of
dropping now down to a spam based
approach and all I'm looking for in this
case is within that span find me the
index of the tab byte and count your
position through and by using that tab
character as the way of identifying
where you are so when you're at tab
count one I know I want to read that
string so all we then do is slice from
in this case the start position to where
that tab is and now we've got some data
that we can immediately cast with string
but we're actually gonna index into
elastics
and we just do that for the items we
want we break out early we only do the
11 tabs because after that we don't care
about the rest of the line so we've done
some optimization by not even parsing
data that we don't care about in terms
of performance gains for this let's look
at the results so I did this test over
75 files of each we have about 10,000
rows because that was kind of
representative of a load I was seen
quite often in the service so in the
original we're about 8 and 1/2 seconds
and we're under a second in the
optimized code that's quite good it's
not like super exciting we move this is
a processing service we could probably
live with 8 and a half seconds but the
allocations was a really telling story 7
gigs of allocations reading through
those files in the original flow because
of that byte array that we're creating
and then that string copy of memory
there's a lot of copying going on
there's a lot of allocations going on
short live allocations we're down to 242
Meg's in the new flow which is quite a
significant drop 30 times roughly less
what was really interesting was 203
megabyte of this strings that I'm
outputting into the data I'm gonna push
into elasticsearch so that means we're
sort of less than 40 mega overhead for
this piece of work to happen now which
is quite significant and actually I can
optimize a lot more of that way because
elasticsearch accepts bytes so I could
actually avoid those string allocations
entirely potentially with my code in the
future so quite a lot of advantages that
we were able to get with pipelines span
in that example so finally I want to
touch on the JSON api's in that came in
donate core free route of interest we
heard of like system text or Jason when
it arrived pretty good number you read
the blog posts so this came in the Box
Microsoft announced it it did cause a
little bit of heat on Twitter when they
first said what they were doing because
everyone started sort of stamping on
Microsoft saying okay you're going after
the open-source community yet again we
have Newton soft Jason we like that why
are you building your own thing now
fortunately to kind of help ease that
the James Newton king who wrote juice
Jason Newton soft Jason came up and
wrote a blog post and explained why he
thinks it's a good idea now to be fair
mark sort of employed in so he's paid to
agree with them but you know hopefully
he his points are fair and he probably
is representing his own viewpoint and
the reasons for this were twofold so one
of the issues was asp net core relies on
JSON parsing quite often in order to do
model binding with data comes in as JSON
and to serialize data out in web api's
this means that for that to work they
have to pin the asp net core version to
a particular work version and newton
soft jason they know works which means
that if you want to use a different
version in an asp net core app you
probably can't because it won't actually
get brought in by new game and that was
a bit of a pain for certain people that
wanted the latest jason features but
were tied back to whatever has been at
core had at the time it was released the
other problem is performance and there
are ways to optimize obviously with
things like span of T but to retrofit
that in to Newton soft JSON which is
installed in so many millions of code
bases which would introduce some kind of
breakages to the API surface would have
been a bit of a nightmare for anyone
that decided to take the next release so
rather than break everyone in the world
they decided it probably makes sense to
just build something in the box because
this is done so often that asp net core
can rely on and optionally you can use
too or you can continue to use Newton
soft Jason there's free layers to the
way they've structured this so at the
bottom level the lowest level that gives
us the most performance we have a utf-8
JSON reader and a utf-8 json writer this
is where it gets really gnarly we'll see
some code for this in a moment but this
allows you to get the most sort of bang
for your buck if you're really looking
for performance then you can work at
this level if you're actually reading
data a slightly more sort of less
verbose way and a slightly efficient way
to do it is with this JSON document type
that they bought this is essentially a
read-only view that in most cases might
not actually even allocate any heap
memory when it's working it gives you
essentially a document object model of
Jason that you can pass your way through
if you want to and then at the very top
level we have a regular serializer and
deserialize err that are optimized they
are quicker than newton soft Jason but
they're sort of less performant than
working at the low-level code yourself
because they have to be a bit more
generic and a bit more general to the
Jason structure they get in those
serialize azar quite sort of feature
limited at this case they were released
with just what was enough for asp net
core serialization
Merilee that is being moved on in new
versions of.net core but just be aware
that a they're limited in features and B
they're quite strict about the Jason
structure new it's off Jason is quite
good at working out what the Jason
probably means even if it's not entirely
valid Jason systems or text or Jason
will just generally throw an exception
if it encounters invalid Jason so this
one is easier to see in practice again
so here I'm going to do an example where
I'm going to index something into an
asset so it doesn't matter if you don't
know what a lastik search is but it has
an operation that's essentially a rest
Empire I can call to pass it some data
to store in the index what I need to do
is when I get the response back I need
to deserialize that response in order to
identify did that operation complete
successfully overall and if it didn't
complete overall successfully which of
the actual things I index failed because
what we want to know is which ones we
have to retry and so this is actually
quite a product at a hard problem to do
in a very efficient way with regular
Jason so let's look at the original code
now the good thing about this code is I
can even at this ridiculous font size
fit the entire method on the screen so
that's good and we're basically just
taking the the Jason text reader over
the stream of data deserializing it to
our type now inside that type basically
the data that you get back from the
elasticsearch API is how long it took
true or false were there any errors or
not and then the collection of all the
items which is the metadata about
everything within the request that we
made what we can say is if there are no
errors at that top level property then
great return that there's no errors a
success true in this case and an empty
array of items that failed because
there's nothing if there are errors then
we have to work our way through it to
find the ones that had a failure code
and then we've got the IDs for those
that failed fantastic so we'll go to the
new approach you can tell by the scroll
bar
it's a bit bigger and again you know you
really have to make a judgment call on
whether this is worthwhile in your
scenarios again some horrible stuff at
the top we can skip over so here we're
using the array pool fantastic so in
this case rather than using pipe lines
I'm going to use streams just natively
so I'm going to create the buffer for
that stream but I'm going to use the
array pool so this gives us the
flexibility to at least not heap
allocate this temporary buffer a lot of
code here so I'll skip over some of it
but ultimately what I'm going to do is
I'm going to read from the stream into
my buffer and then I'm gonna try and
pause the errors and I pass a lot of
stuff in by reference here because I'm
gonna track my state as I come into this
method because I might not have the
entire JSON blob in one go I possibly
won't
so inside parse errors we're gonna use
this utf-8 JSON reader this also takes
this is final block boolean and some
state so this is a reaction type accepts
the possibility you're working with
streams or data that's coming in in
chunks so it allows you just to kind of
keep calling it with the last state that
you had and it can keep parsing through
further and further into the JSON and
ultimately what we call is JSON don't
read and inside here once we've done
that we basically get the token that
we're at and we're low-level now with
we're looking at the opening curly brace
of an object or we're looking at the
start of an array but we have these
tokens that we can work through and all
this horrible horrible switch cut who
does is try more account with the known
structure that I know I'm getting where
is the errors property and what's its
value true or false on that one and
potentially if I need to the items the
interesting thing I can do here is if I
found the errors property here and then
on my next loop through if I find false
as the value of that property then I'm
gonna break out of here and essentially
if I come back up here I short-circuit
the whole process and say well if
there's no errors found or I found the
errors property and it has no errors
stop if that's that's no errors in that
document I don't need to pass through
the rest of the JSON at all that's
within the first like 20 bytes of the
JSON so I can optimize this code to
avoid parsing anything I don't care
about only in this sort of failure case
would it then have to go through and
identify and find all of those relevant
IDs for the messages that failed again
you can kind of a look at that code at
your own leisure
if you're bored on a Sunday evening but
otherwise I'll jump through to the
results which are a little more fun so
in the failure response scenario and I
totally frustrated with the numbers
because I'm sure there's more
performance and this is the one risk you
run with performance every time you see
an allocation you'll be like that so
even here although we've gone down from
114 K to 16 K in the failure scenario at
16 K feels like failure but you know
this is a pretty good game but the
failing response is really unlikely in
our case we're not expecting things to
fail on the indexing process so that
success response is more interesting I
skip over those so the except success
response here in the optimize flow is so
so much quicker because we read the
first 20 bytes we see if there's no
errors and we just dump doing any more
work and we only allocate frustratingly
80 bytes that really should be zero and
I need to spend some time in this code
to figure out where 80 bytes is coming
from but you know it's good enough as a
prototype and we've we've proved that in
this sort of 99% case we are saving a
fair amount of allocations on what is
going to be a fairly heavy and common
operation in this particular scenario so
we're sort of wrapping up now we're
getting towards the ends and the
important thing you might be thinking is
great I want to do some of this how do I
get work to let me to do it
one you can be sneaky and just do it and
kind of that's what I've done here all
of these prototypes are little lunchtime
projects that I've done here and there
where I've seen things that might be
interesting to take this forward what I
suggest is you look for one of those
kind of things like I did where I saw
heavy allocations in my case we had one
service that was actually falling over
because of the memory allocation so that
was a clue we should probably do
something but even then you know just
looking at that code casually you can
see that array allocation the string
allocation was heavy heap allocation so
see some look for something like that
where you can kind of say yeah that's
really bad then use this scientific
method of actually measuring first
optimizing a small piece of code
measure again to give you these numbers
that actually let you quantify what
you've achieved do not go to the product
owner and go I've shaved 1000 bytes off
of this particular method and it's now
only 400 nanoseconds because they won't
give a damn all their ones
really what you're babbling on about so
turn this into a monetary value try and
establish for them what the value of
this is and give them some kind of cost
to benefit ratio of you spending time
doing this in in work time or real time
to actually move this forward so this is
one example we had so we have a service
that's an input process so this is one
of the things that's doing kind of 18
million messages a day so fairly common
high volume workloads and so what I did
is all of these individual prototypes
plus a few I haven't had time to show
you where attempts at finding various
parts of that flow that I could
potentially optimize after some sort of
like maybe slightly positively biased
estimations I've said that I think I can
reduce 50% of the allocations inside
this little micro Service and I can
probably double it throughput based on
the execution time changes that I'm
seeing for the various phases so then
what I've done is gone and looked at how
much scaling this service is having to
do inside our container cluster to
figure out actually I can probably get
rid of enough scaling that means I save
one VM you know in our cluster on a sort
of daily basis which is in our situation
about $1,700 a year for that that one
service change now that might not be
enough to justify a developer spending
their time on it but some of those
processes particularly in micro services
if you're doing a lot of data
manipulation you'll be doing the same
thing time and time again in lots of
services and if you can just kind of
stamp and replace similar parsing logic
for those particular requirements we can
ramp this up quite quickly at scale
across the many hundreds of services we
might be talking about so you can start
to show this value and you can then sort
of see if you can get the business
strategy to buy into this idea of
actually optimizing the code again where
it's contextually worth doing if there's
a good cost saving and the code doesn't
change much this might be good for you
so in summary because this has like been
a lot of stuff for and afternoon I can't
remember what I said at the start
everything you've seen is really
importantly mostly for advanced
situations so this isn't stuff you go
back to office on Monday and go whoa I'm
changing everything expounds going
everywhere it's really tempting and when
you start is hard to stop but you know
use some use some caution around where
you're applying it measure everything
don't assume assume in this case can be
really dangerous around you know making
changes that are actually degrading
performance or having a knock-on effect
elsewhere that you just couldn't
actually even foresee
be scientific in that so benchmark
dotnet is a fantastic quite easy tool to
get going with initially that gives you
these kind of accurate numbers that you
can work against focus on the hot past
don't spend all your time optimizing
something that's called once in a blue
moon it might be fantastically you get
zero allocations but is that actually
going to change your life in time in
terms of that services overall code so
don't copy memory where you can slice it
work with the span API is when you're
doing parsing of strings or byte data
use those array pools that's quite a
quick and easy change you can ply with
fairly insignificant code changes
actually and it's still fairly readable
code when you finish it it's not quite
as bad as some of those demos I showed
you overall pipelines is great for
you've got a lot of i/o can keep that in
mind there and the new API is for Jason
if you are doing that JSON parsing as
I've shown you can make some really
efficient sort of API calls and parsing
of the responses you're getting with
that kind of API one book I recommend
product net memory management Conrad's
here at the conference he spoke
yesterday on 0 GC fantastic book it's
about this thick and if you carry it
around only where you get stronger but
you're protected at night if someone
comes on the tax you swing your bag you
kill them it's really worth having and
this is where I've learned a lot of what
I've seen in here about how networks
around memory and how you optimize and
you span I'll leave the link up with the
slide there again if you want to get in
touch afterwards please do follow me
I'll tweet about this asp net core and
gin or you can check my blog which is
limited to actual technical stuff
otherwise thank you very much time's up
thank you
[Applause]